greetings from podcastville
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings
from the heart of new jersey uncle joey
is slinging dick with draftkings let me
explain something to you
this week we got some great games as a
matter of fact tonight you got the
kansas city chiefs
versus the buffalo bills they go head to
head if you think mahones is going to
deliver for kc
you got to put your money where your
mouth is you also got the world series
you also got [ __ ] khabib this week
you got a thousand things to [ __ ]
work with draftkings is america's top
rated
sportsbook app if you haven't tried it
yet this is the time
to jump on because they're giving all
new users
a chance to receive a sign-in bonus of
one
thousand dollars when you use code joey
they put one grand they give you one
grand
who else has given you anything these
days nobody you can't even get
unemployment on the [ __ ] phone
so download the top rated draftking
sports but i
now and use code joey j-o-e-y
to get a thousand dollars you didn't
[ __ ] hear me
you get one grand when you get draft
king sportsbook out and use code joey
only at draftkings sportsbook the best
[ __ ] sports book in the [ __ ] world
do you understand me
they got everything there and here's the
part the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 or older deposit
requires a 25-time playthrough
restrictions to apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details okay you got a
gaming problem
there's help call 1-800 gambler if
you're in indiana call 1-809
with it but first download draftking
sportbook app
and use code joey the church wants to
welcome
honey listen you know how it is these
days
everybody's going online to shop it's
[ __ ] a little annoying
but these days especially with the move
i feel like every day i got to fire some
up the computer and buy something else
online the remote my shoe
the [ __ ] generator the macbook that's
where today's sponsor comes in
honey they really come in handy it's a
free browser extension
which is like a little ferry that lives
inside your computer who looks all over
the internet for promo codes
to save you money so it's easy just
download honey
at joinhoney.com
joey it's simple if you got a computer
honey should be on it
it's free and it works with whatever
browser you use
you can get honey for free today at
joinhoney.com
joey j-o-e-y that's join honey.com
joey j-o-e-y for [ __ ] results
the church is also brought to you by
blue chew
guys remember the days when your dick
was [ __ ] hard and the [ __ ]
bodybuilder
remember you give your [ __ ] lady a
stab and it looks like she went through
the [ __ ] ring on her head would be
all [ __ ] up
after i [ __ ] pulled my hamstring i
started [ __ ] suffering with lipstick
it's a [ __ ] nightmare now i'm not
judging nobody but if you got a weak
wood
uncle joey's got the fix blue chew
[ __ ]
these two little bills is the first
chewable dickbill
same fda approved acting of ingredients
as viagra
and cialis and right now i got a special
offer for the [ __ ] joint family visit
bluetooth
bluetooth what do you mean bluetooth
bluetooth.com
that's bluechew.com and get your first
shipment free when you press in code
joey j-o-e-y
you just paid five dollars for chipping
that's it again that's blue
like the color of your [ __ ] dick
don't get no
[ __ ] you understand me just go to blue
chew
dog and they're gonna rock your [ __ ]
world go to bluetooth.com and use promo
coach joey
that's bluechew.com use promo code
joey thank you for continuing to sponsor
the show
and now let the joint begin where's this
[ __ ] lighter
it's a beautiful day to be alive
[ __ ] it's monday
october 19th
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here it's monday
october 19th welcome to uncle joey's
joint
by the way it's a [ __ ] two months to
the day
that i left l.a today if i would have
told you right now
i mean when i before i left i was like
by the time i [ __ ] leave ella you
know
two months what am i gonna feel like i
gotta tell you something i can't even
describe to you the change
it's been great and thanks to you guys
for watching the podcast and working
with me
we've been able to work this [ __ ]
thing out but it's going to rough up in
two months but the last month is finally
straightened out i'm getting a little
scheduled down
which is the most important thing that
had knowings i had my [ __ ] anxiety
going off the rails
was i had no schedule i'm still living
kind of day to day
to the [ __ ] minute you know but at
least we got a little bit more under our
feet to work with uh
you know i lift mondays and thursdays my
daughter's back in school four days a
week
thank [ __ ] god starting today so it
gives me a little bit more flexibility
so it's like what i said all the pieces
have come [ __ ] together jack
i had a great [ __ ] weekend i don't
know how you guys and weekend went i'll
tell you one thing
i got my friday night i didn't do dick i
think uh
somebody came over to eat dinner or
something like that somebody just
stopped by that was it
saturday night my wife went out and i
stayed home with the baby just because
saturday nights i got my [ __ ]
schedule down listen
for the last 20 years 29 years i've been
out on a [ __ ] saturday night
every [ __ ] saturday out hustling
spots
i remember when i first started in 90
[ __ ] four
when i first really got into it i used
to [ __ ] go oh
on saturday nights i used to drive like
an hour and a half
to do a spot a show that started at 11
and the guy would put me on
last because he [ __ ] thought it was
too dirty so i would have to sit there
till 1 30 in the [ __ ] morning
so i've been going on saturday nights
for [ __ ] close to 29 [ __ ] years
so finally i found out that on saturday
nights here in jersey
it's my night starting at nine o'clock i
don't have to do nothing
except get stoned as a matter of fact
happy monday
[Music]
i get the party started at some time on
a monday morning you know what i'm
saying
but saturday nights is my night wpix is
still throwing some heat at me
[ __ ] when i was a kid wpix is channel
11.
i would [ __ ] watch that every goddamn
night because you had the yacht cup what
eleven
the honeymoon is 11 30. sanford and son
of 12
and the twilight zone at 12 30 and wr at
10 30 had betty hill
god forget god forbid a tip pop out and
you didn't [ __ ] watch it
but that's not my point now 20 [ __ ]
30 40 years later
wpix on saturday night has the lineup of
death and it's perfect for me
because i got archie bunker on that nine
i got the
honeymooners on at 9 30 and this is
where it gets better
boom i got an hour in between
so that means i don't feel [ __ ] that
lazy like i don't have to sit there for
[ __ ] three hours and watch tv
so at ten my wife usually goes to bed at
ten i'll get up five after ten i'll get
up and do some work on the computer
maybe roll a [ __ ] joint maybe do
something i need to do the night before
a promo whatever the [ __ ] it is and then
at 11
bam i got two more episodes of the
honeymooners
so i can't [ __ ] lose it's like a
[ __ ] doctor i stay in completely
i get my little hood it's when you put a
sweatshirt when you see a hoodie
sweatshirt uncle joey
you know i'm going down i either got a
red one or one of felipe's blue ones
or a black [ __ ] jiu jitsu one that uh
whatever sent me fuji sent me those are
my pajama sweatshirts
well i usually don't put those
[ __ ] on till like 9 30 on
saturday
bam those [ __ ] come on like 7
30 doug
because i know my fate you wouldn't get
me out of the house on a saturday at
least not for the [ __ ] remainder of
the year
i'm locked in on saturdays that's my
reefer night i do a little edible
you know it's funny because i was
talking to lee uh saturday night
and he was telling me he goes then i eat
you somebody put a 200 milligram
in my 100 milligram i wonder who it was
i'm like two months [ __ ] later
you're still talking about these edibles
i supposedly put in your [ __ ] thing
no what's going on is i resist you know
our tolerance is going down
when the [ __ ] do i eat edibles now what
i don't listen
california part of it was a [ __ ]
i we did edibles every [ __ ] day i did
an edible every day at some point of the
[ __ ] day
you know and eventually when i came back
yeah i couldn't my anxiety was too high
that that edible [ __ ] went out the
window the night
that there was an earthquake here in
freehold new jersey there was an
earthquake like [ __ ] 20 miles from
here and free old everybody kept saying
new jersey
you brought the [ __ ] earthquake with
either that of the earthquake
i was [ __ ] up i'm not gonna lie to you
people there are nights that i go
rogue i can't sleep and i start eating
[ __ ] edibles and i go rogue i get i
got those hashtags or the pro tabs
from urban trees and they're just 25
milligrams
if i really want listen i made a mistake
last week
last week i had a [ __ ] capsule on
here on sunday at
10 in the morning and by 2 o'clock i'm
like these [ __ ] 200 milligrams
aren't doing [ __ ] to me maybe maybe my
tolerance is wrong
holy [ __ ] about 3 30 i went over to my
friends to watch football
i was [ __ ] up for like an hour and a
half i mean
[ __ ] up nodding i was calf falling
asleep
but then i ate a chicken wing and i was
back like a [ __ ] doctor
a chicken wing and a piece of shrimp and
i was [ __ ] back and that was it
but i'm like i got pretty [ __ ] up
there so i didn't mess around with them
the rest of the week
but wednesday night i went down uncle
vinnie's listen i got four shows down
there i told you [ __ ] that this
is gonna be
just an experiment to see but here's the
funny thing
i went down uncle vinnie's and i ate a
bag of dicks this past wednesday night i
only got four things there for the month
of october
i got some [ __ ] going on in november but
i went down uncle vinnie's last
wednesday
and i ate a bag of dicks my timing was
off
my material was off i couldn't remember
my [ __ ] material
i was so upset i haven't bombed that
hard
at a show
and probably 20 years i was so [ __ ]
upset
i came home and they like [ __ ] sick
first of all
why am i bullshitting you guys i had
these uh these hashtags
and i had like maybe six left in the
bottom of a baggie i didn't have time to
take two out
just to put in my little drug pocket so
i took the whole baggie with me
and on the way back from the show i was
so visibly upset
i just don't like bombing like that that
i ate all [ __ ] six pills
by the time i got home and i [ __ ]
took a shower and i went out to the
living room
i was [ __ ] on fire in that living
room
i mean drooling the whole [ __ ] thing
i drank the tea
once i drink my little thct it's lights
out there's something i listen
one night i fell asleep with the tea all
i have to do is just sip it sometimes
i put it on my lap one night i fell
asleep because the t spilled down my lap
and it was still hot remember the fat
chicken
the coffee hit her legs from mcdonald's
and then she sued mcdonald's i just had
no i had nobody to sue i could just do
myself
all i got to do is taste the [ __ ]
thct
i break them up i either do the sleepy
time or the thct
whatever t it is it doesn't matter i
just do two sips sometimes and i'm
[ __ ] it just puts me right the [ __ ]
over
you know there's some thc products uh i
do the melatonin from
from [ __ ] on it so some nights i eat
an edible
and i eat those [ __ ] sleep products
and i go
deep deep deep off the murky waters
you know ever since wednesday i've been
a little good this week last night i
didn't do no [ __ ] edibles
i just sprayed a couple sprays but even
this spray a couple weeks ago
i was [ __ ] around with you guys and i
was doing the mint spray in the daytime
jesus christ about three hours later i
looked at myself in the mirror my
[ __ ] eyes were beat red my eyelids
were [ __ ] red
i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
listen
it was a rough [ __ ] eight years and
we slowed the [ __ ] down what do you
think is gonna [ __ ] happen
back to the bombing on wednesday when i
understand about this bombing was
and a lot of people probably tell you oh
no joey doesn't bro
i bomb and this is the problem here's
the problem i couldn't understand
the wednesday before i didn't do
anything
i went down there without even looking
at my computer without looking at notes
without looking at nothing
and i did six out of ten i did okay i
used some old jokes
i talked about some new topics this
[ __ ] wednesday
i [ __ ] got up at six in the morning
and i worked on my material from
six in the morning till nine in the
[ __ ] morning till my daughter got on
the
[ __ ] computer this is what baffles me
about this
that i actually worked on my [ __ ] set
and i got to tell you something i go
back to leon this here lee told me one
time i
i don't like when you do sets before a
special you're too tight and it's true
when i prepare myself and i try to
[ __ ] do good
i eat a bag of dicks because i'm too
over prepared
i gotta go out there on a [ __ ] loose
and just go [ __ ] robots
if not it just doesn't work out so this
week i'm doing a hybrid
like i'm gonna do material i'm gonna
write material i wrote some this morning
i wrote some yesterday i wrote some
saturday night during that hour that's
what i did this week during that hour
i just went over my material i'm gonna
do some material tomorrow
and then wednesday i'm not gonna do [ __ ]
so there's no pressure on myself like i
said
i'm just looking at different [ __ ]
avenues here to see how i'm gonna attack
this [ __ ] stand up
i got a movie i'm gonna do in november
i'm gonna be away from it and then we'll
see what the [ __ ]
thing is going on what things are going
on before the
uh after the election see i'm not
worried about the election
as much as the other thing that people
are looking at you ever seen before a
tropical storm comes
people are saying there's a storm out
there brewing there's a storm brewing
but it's not in [ __ ] it's not the
election
and it's not california and it's not
seattle and it's not [ __ ] portland
it's not austin
it's minneapolis keep your eyes on
minneapolis last friday
the judge let in the tape from the whole
george floyd thing
i'm not trying to be political i'm just
letting you know to keep your eyes open
for this
because it's going to come out people
are worried about the election and
covert
i want you to worry about what's going
on in minneapolis
as a [ __ ] law freak here's a law and
order freak
you guys aren't watching it they let the
guy out on bail
and now they allowed the whole
tape they want a whole tape of the
interaction of what happened before
to see and he was like pushing the
fentanyl thing
remember your uncle joey told you that
remember uncle joey ain't wrong when he
talked to me about these things
everybody's worried about the election
everybody's worried about covert in the
winter
my big worry is what's going on in
minneapolis
keep your eyes open on that okay
remember i told you
don't let that slip out of your [ __ ]
conscience because that's in the middle
of the country
that's in minneapolis right there in the
middle and that connects denver
that connects chicago keep your eyes
open
remember you heard it from your uncle
[ __ ] joey i wouldn't lie to you
[ __ ]
and with that i got to talk to you about
something beside the bombing
and beside all this [ __ ] last week i was
talking about
uh bill burke going on snl and
i made some remarks about the [ __ ]
schools and i
a couple people reached out to me and
what i was trying to say was this
okay let's go back to the beginning of
this
over the last 10 11 12 years i've been
on the computer
[ __ ] around talking to you guys
messaging with you guys
whatever every once in a while
once a week somebody a young comic
i don't even know if they're young i'm
just saying somebody who's new to comedy
will send me a uh
[ __ ] tape and say can you please
watch my comedy and give me advice
and i always write back the same thing
listen number one
i'm not good at that [ __ ] and number two
i'm the wrong guy to ask
because i'm not here to [ __ ] bust
you your dream to bust your [ __ ]
bubble
when it comes to comedy listen when i
was living my real life [ __ ] around
out there stealing and doing all that
[ __ ] yes
i was a reckless but when it comes to
comedy
and a dream i'm by the book what are you
talking about a dream joey
when it comes to somebody's dream when
somebody comes to me
and they say i want to be in a band or
whatever i don't cut their legs off if
somebody says to me i want to start a
band
i don't cut their legs off if somebody
says to me what do you think about my
music
i don't cut my legs off because i'm not
here
to tell you whether you're good or bad
at what the [ __ ] you do
especially when i come when it comes to
comedy you put me in a bad position
because that's not what i do you take a
guy like joe rogan for example
joe rogan is a very generous decent guy
who i've known for 23 years
has always been a positive [ __ ] force
in my life
and i'll tell you what you think about
our friendship
our friendship is not do you think joe
rogan want to listen to my cocaine
stories not really
you think you're a regular to my
criminal stories not really
our friendship is based on my respect
for comedy and what he saw from me
as a comedian when it comes to comedy me
and joe rogan are
[ __ ] the dearest friends in the world
trust me we're on a plane
we're not talking about me robbing
somebody or me doing this and we're
doing that
we're talking about what we see in
communists and in its eyes that's why
him and i that's our direct
connection if you want to know why he's
my friend
it's because he knows the respect i have
for comedy
comics people who are doing comedy
i respect anybody who's taken a [ __ ]
chance in their life
i really do because you could just fall
into the norm
i respect anybody who's doing it outside
in a rebellious way
from within and they're being honest
with themselves there's people who are
just out there yahoos they're talking to
themselves
and they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're saying they're those people too
but i see some young comics you know and
you've seen them on my podcast
if they won the old podcast at church it
was because i had some sort of respect
for them
you might not have known them or you
might have never seen them on a tv show
and they were on a tv show but i was
watching that progress within the comedy
community
and when you guys would say why would
you put that person on they're not a
known person i don't give a [ __ ] but you
know or you not know
i know about them i know what they're
doing and i know the work they're
putting in
so what thing that bothered me the most
one of the things that i could read
me the most about la's greed is what
they do
to a young person's dream i know a lot
of women are going to raise their hands
on this a lot of men are going to raise
their hand on this
listen it's a [ __ ] nightmare you got
acting classes you got high-end acting
classes
you used to have improv olympic you used
to have
groundlings and you used to have the
other one
up by uh which i don't know a lot of
these names
but what i want to tell you was i wasn't
putting them down last week
i'll tell you what i was putting down
i was putting down the system that they
use on most people
okay that and i'll explain it to you
step by step
number one there's people who go to la
let's just take it for the comedies i i
could talk about music
but i really wouldn't know i could talk
about photography i could talk about
any of one of the arts let's just keep
it the comedy for right now
because that's the one i know about for
sure okay
when you come to l.a
as a comic you come to la with a little
bit of [ __ ] experience
you come to a la already knowing what
time it is and knowing what position
you're getting yourself into
those are comedians when an actor comes
to l.a
he's either done regional theater
theater in new york theater in chicago
maybe shot a few movies in his hometown
he was an extra
and they shot a movie because you know
they shoot movies everywhere so you know
it's not like before that you had to
live in california they shoot movies and
[ __ ] uh
new orleans whatever and if you just
happen to be lucky
you might get a day on that stuff so you
have you have an idea
of what you're coming to life with and
you have an idea that you have to get
into an acting class
and hey listen when i went to la i was
told not to go to an acting class and
between you and i
i thought it was a bad idea and that's
why
when i did the bronx county [ __ ]
pilot they cut my lines down to one line
that's why i did the nbc show i wasn't
that good on that show that's
when i did basketball i wasn't that good
on that after all those three things i
was like and the taco bell commercial
i didn't really know what i was doing
yes the potential was there
but i didn't know what i was doing so me
myself
being who the [ __ ] i am in my world
that i'm a dumb [ __ ] and i know this i
signed up for a basic acting class on
monday nights
it was an italian guy the guy did not
like comics he was not
comic friendly but i sacked it was
[ __ ]
for like four or five months on monday
nights at the time
monday nights was the hottest [ __ ]
night in l.a
so i used to have to go down there
do my scene and leave which is not fair
to anybody else and it wasn't fair to me
it wasn't fair that what i was doing to
the class
at the time i only had one credit i had
uh bronx county
or whatever the [ __ ] so nobody really
talked like nobody really talked to me
nobody really wanted to talk about
anything
as time progressed i got his name was
meghna
something magna and his class was on
straight it was up the corner from where
me ralphie
around the corner from my [ __ ] stan
hope we all lived there
there was a little acting class on
schroeder in fact if you go behind that
alley
i think you guys heard it when duff
mckagan was on the church
guns and roses lived in a garage back
there so behind that area there there
was like uh
something meghana frank magna him and
his wife taught an acting class and
across the street there was another act
that's like actorsville down there in
hollywood this was like a cheap class
100 bucks a month
you know 25 a week you paid as you came
you know that type of [ __ ] i could live
with that at the time
then somebody talked me into advantage
of it
who that's a great acting [ __ ] school
it's a great school
and you go to the program you start the
beginners well i did tuesday mornings
ten to one was the beginner program that
went from a hundred dollars
to 225 and it was great
um i was into it you know
i wasn't getting any mileage on my stand
up
so i figured let me go to the [ __ ]
back door
the sopranos came out and all of a
sudden i started getting
you know people started calling me in
for more roles so i said if i'm going to
do this i might as well [ __ ] be
prepared i've blown
30 auditions already so i signed up with
advantage obviously irvana chubby had a
great reputation
there was a couple other acting schools
that had great reputations
but even if i went and did uh you you
could sit on them i forget what you call
that
when you sit on a class i went and sat
on all of them and the guy i liked the
most was an advantage shot because i
didn't shop because a woman
but she has teachers that teach her uh i
forget the guy that
i was there's a sweetheart of a guy he's
gonna probably watch this and get pissed
off
but i got a lot of [ __ ] on my mind he
was a sweet heart of a guy
and guess what he gave me the tools i
needed
mixed with what i was doing at the
comedy store at night mixed with
mitzi's three-minute rule on [ __ ]
sunday on
sunday nights and monday nights all that
mixed together
i figured out how to act just to get by
i did a bunch of little movies if you
look at my mdb you'll see it
but then what happened was
i did a cold reading workshop and i met
this guy
uh christian kaplan christian kaplan
was a great guy he was gay guy he was a
great guy i loved him
he's doing something animation at fox
now he was a great guy he taught me how
to cold read
cold read means how to when you get to
an audition
they just give you a sheet of paper
sometimes and they say learn that
right now you got five minutes to
[ __ ] make the call
and you got five minutes to read this
[ __ ] and make your call on how you're
gonna read this or how you're gonna
[ __ ] go back in that room
and blow them away that's what it was
guys that's that's it
there's no [ __ ] you're the real world
they give you a sheet
you know some some auditions send you
the [ __ ] audition
the night before that's fine some places
don't want you to know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
so they give you they'll tell you pick
up sides at the door and then you have
to give them back to them before you
leave
that was 50 percent of my struggle that
they just give you the sides
you gotta [ __ ] outline it with a
yellow [ __ ]
magic marker and then put lines around
it
christian kaplan taught me how to break
it down to a [ __ ] science
and then i also went to a workshop that
was run by the guy who cast godfather 2
and sleepers and donnie brass i forgot
his name right off the bat you got imdb
i went to his cast and director seminar
those two [ __ ] workshops
helped me book people helped me book
learn taught me how to book tv shows
movies
plays whatever i had it down so i was an
acting class between us
i drank the whatever the kool-aid if
that's what you want to call it
i was an acting class all together for
about a year
i went to magna
i had this uh african-american guy for
around
a while that was gay also he was a
little sick
but [ __ ] could teach you [ __ ]
to look for in an audition you know he's
the one that guided me through
uh when travolta was going to play a
musician
and he had two stand-ups opening frame i
forget the whole
plot of the thing i forget the guy's
name he was a guy from hoboken
and his two stand-ups are going to be me
and billy gardell
and then travolta chose to [ __ ] do a
scientology movie that
sucked dick and [ __ ] crashed and
burned so they canceled that thing but
when i was doing
all through that movie that's who
[ __ ] coached me it was that
african-american gay guy
somewhere along the line he got sick
that movie [ __ ] went away
and then i got my hand i had to go to
event chubby
the whole time i spent an acting class
was about a year
but i learned something from that acting
class
number two when i did alice
finally james coburn pulled me aside one
day
i put that clip up on patreon about a
month ago
somebody sent it to me i had never even
seen that [ __ ] thing me and alice
james coburn
he pulled me aside and he goes are you
an acting class and i go yeah he goes
get the [ __ ] out
because it's going to take away i could
tell you have natural ability whatever
the [ __ ]
so i stopped going acting class that's
what got me out of acting class now
the reason i have a problem and i don't
have a problem with advantage topic at
all or any of those coaches at all
but there were a lot of coaches that
were running [ __ ] scams
they would take they would charge you
260 270 a [ __ ] month
120 i know a lady that was charging 120
to coach you for a half hour who could
[ __ ] do that who can afford that
that's insane so what happened in l.a
was what happens is yeah
50 of the people that go there like
myself
knew exactly what i wanted to do but
there was this other 50 percent
that nobody knows about and it's these
college kids
they go to college they get a great
[ __ ] degree
great [ __ ] you know history law
whatever but in their frat on their
sorority
they start watching sunlight live on
saturdays
and by the time they graduate they tell
their parents listen
we don't want to go to [ __ ] we don't
want to go to work for the family
business or whatever
we want to become an actor can you give
us a year out in l.a
those guys get [ __ ] killed
those guys those young kids that decide
in college
that they want to go out to la and
either become actors
or they want to be on snl
they're poor [ __ ] kids by the time
they get to l.a their dad
he doesn't know better their dad or your
mom gives them a credit card
they move out to la they get the [ __ ]
apartment
and then they run into one of those
[ __ ] acting people
and let me tell you something or one of
those improv schools
and the improv schools and the acting
coaches there's a lot of good ones
there's a lot of great ones if you're
ever going to join one and you need to
you know ask me whatever and i'll tell
you but there's a lot of bad programs
there's a lot of bad programs that they
don't let you work
until they get five or ten grand out of
you i'm not
[ __ ] kidding you they will tell you
right i know one program in beverly
hills that was scientology based
that while you took their acting course
for 18 months
you were not allowed to audition are you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] that was pissing me off
so those theaters yes
for guys like me that had [ __ ]
mentors and they told me like listen
don't
get out of that class get out don't fall
for that [ __ ]
go in there learn what you have to learn
how to break down an audition learn how
to read a [ __ ] script
learn how to make choices with your
character and then move on because those
people
will put a [ __ ] limit on what you can
and can't do it was
[ __ ] insane or they'll tell you
you're not ready because you haven't
taken all my program
okay what are the programs you have to
offer you have an acting class
and you have a co-reading class that's
it in my world
no not in l.a they got movement
breathing you know how to add dance to
your [ __ ] what do you need dance for
you a [ __ ] tap dancer
so they'll run you through a [ __ ]
program there's a big time acting school
that i still get emails from in la
i haven't unsubscribed i i subscribe to
them
because i want to learn the scams they
could do listen guys
listen to me i didn't need to do comedy
after i got the longest yarn i could
have quit
and just opened up an acting school and
milk kids to death
i could have gone to [ __ ] little open
mics
in l.a picked out sheep listen you know
me dog
i'm a [ __ ] thief all the way to the
end i could have picked out little young
kids that would have known better
and said to them come here how would you
like to be [ __ ] trained i could take
you to the top
i could do this i can help you right i
help you get seen
dog there's a thousand comics that do
that [ __ ] in that way
that figure out that time is done they
get one or two credits
you think they're [ __ ] god's gift to
the world and then they start private
coaching
taking these kids money for everything
they [ __ ] got but it doesn't stop
there
it also stops with those acting classes
and those [ __ ] comedy [ __ ] places
i'm not saying that bad and i'm not
mentioning that i'm not making any bad
remarks about them
i'm not you know i'm not in business to
[ __ ] go to war with nobody
i'm just telling you what i observed
over the years i had one friend
that i had gone to havana chubby with
him
in 2003. i bumped into him in like 2012
and he was now enrolled at a completely
different acting [ __ ] institute
and do you know that in nine years
he still hasn't been at a [ __ ]
audition
by 2015 he called me
and he had become an agent
that's so for 10 years he paid a
[ __ ] acting institute
at an average of 300 a month let's just
say
two something a month plus one workshop
a month
that's 400 a month that's 4
000 a year that's 4 800 a [ __ ] year
excuse me not to mention ah
gotta get some juice in whatever you
give that little covered cough you know
what i'm saying
and that's not to mention all the other
[ __ ] that goes around let me tell you
some of you people
that complained about jennifer aniston
and
oh well they had people who helped them
get through the thing their parents were
famous actors let me tell you something
you [ __ ] dummies
i met so many famous kids
at those acting classes that it was
pathetic
i met athlete kids like professional
athletes that i looked up to
i met their kids in acting class there
was one kid
that his father was a well-known [ __ ]
quarterback
i'm not throwing anybody under the bus
here
i knew this kid when i was rocking and
rolling like in 2004
movie wise he had just come to l.a
and you know he found that i was a
stand-up
and he started coming to the comedy
store and watching me
and he was a great kid he was good
looking
uh i thought he was smart you know he
was handsome
he had a little bit of go-getter to him
i i wasn't sure
you know could he act and could he do
i mean
but he was a nice kid i bumped into him
maybe two years ago
at a restaurant and this kid was still
he still hadn't booked anything he was
still getting the acting class
personal training pro you know i think
he had like [ __ ]
you know like the big motivator guy in
his ear his father paid for him
this guy couldn't win in [ __ ] sin
city god bless his soul and i'm not
putting them down
but after a few years you know or not if
you got something like after a few years
in l.a
i after like three or four years if you
have if you're still booking [ __ ] uh
uh you know festival films and you're
still [ __ ] booking like college films
ah you know you have to look at your day
like listen and at first i was going for
college feelings because i didn't know
how to [ __ ] the act
you know how many [ __ ] college films
i shot tons
all of them for free and all of them
were overnight you got to shoot you got
to stay up all [ __ ] night and shoot
them
i shot tons of them i shot a short film
one time with these chinese guys
and all they shot with my feet i nev i
went to the [ __ ] premiere
and it was just a movie about feet
people's feet running i never
these camera people all they shot was
from my knees down
i shot so many [ __ ] bad movies guys
that you would [ __ ] smack me if you
saw me
and i put them up i'm not even ashamed
of them i shot stacy's mom i just put
that one up when i'm yelling at the kids
i'm calling them [ __ ]
you think they're in the room they're
not really in the room it was just a
camera on me
calling a bunch of [ __ ] and then
they put the kids in and took a picture
and they wouldn't let those kids hear
that language
and then when i walked through as the
cooking teacher then i had to say
whatever i had to say but i didn't say
nothing but dog
i shot a thousand of those so for every
longer shot
for every soprano movie for every
[ __ ] spider-man
and for every [ __ ] taxi and all that
[ __ ]
think of me shooting 20 bad [ __ ]
movies movies that
you're sitting there going tell me that
they're not doing this
you know because there's always somebody
you know when you do those shitty movies
there's always somebody in that cast
that got the role because they're
sleeping with the producer
or the sleeper with the financier you
know
uh 2013 when i started getting balls
like
when i started telling people no on the
short films anymore no 100
films it was because of one particular
[ __ ] project
that they were driving me crazed like i
noticed that i was picking up all these
hundred dollar a day films
and i was picking up just shitty i was
getting shitty offers for [ __ ]
and i had already done the longest shot
[ __ ] my name is earl
i had already done all these movies i'm
getting all these shitty [ __ ] offers
and one day i this guy called me up
and he's like hey really like to meet
you for this [ __ ] short series about
the mob
no brainer i go to meet him and the guys
i just wanted to ask him i go so who
else is
in the cast and he looked at me he's
like maybe two or three people that you
know
he told me to run down and then he told
me that he had to cast particular people
with no acting experience just because
they were paying for the [ __ ] movie
like so the one lead was a [ __ ] guy
that was paid like his father paid for
the movie
and that he wanted his wife in the
[ __ ] movie and i'm like
no i'm not doing this [ __ ] no more but
that there are people
that actually pay to [ __ ] be in a
movie if you look at that movie i did
on my mdb there's a [ __ ] stupid movie
i did something in the hedo hanging in
heato
that was a movie
that was a [ __ ] stripper
who her dream was to be in a movie
so the strip club owner wanted a [ __ ]
so the strip cup
club owner borrowed a quarter of a
million dollars
are you listening to what i'm telling
you guys a quarter of a million dollars
and whatever money he had and put
together this movie
in [ __ ] jamaica that was god-awful
and he made the stripper the lead
this stripper was beat up syphilis had
gone through her
she looked like a [ __ ] village after
covert went through it this poor woman
and he put her in this movie luckily i
got fired
the [ __ ] first day because i asked
for uh
uh the money they give you every [ __ ]
day they're supposed to give you cash
every [ __ ] day sixty dollars a day
eighty dollars a day for per diem
when i got there they didn't have no per
diem i go where's the [ __ ] per diem
they go the money got stuck
in california and florida or wherever
the [ __ ] they were from dc i go what do
you mean the money got stuck in dc
it's like yeah we can't give it to you
for about a week i go what are you doing
and meanwhile the chickens doing blow
they're [ __ ] drinking rum at the
bottom like no no
and then they once i asked them for the
pedium and the contract
they were like it's better that you go
home sure it's better than i go home
because you guys are running a [ __ ]
scam here the guy was telling me that
night he goes nah she's the star of the
movie they got
uh they got uh the black chick from
[ __ ] baywatch who was a nobody at
that time
they got poor george jefferson who was
on his last leg he was like 90. he had
one foot in the grave won a banana peel
and they got this [ __ ] fat little guy
i knew that i loved with all my heart me
and steve samoa
we've discussed them fat james fat james
in the movie and i felt so bad for fat
james because he had a [ __ ] stay
there
he was like nah joey you made a mistake
and i'm like james it's okay
i'm gonna leave you could stay i know
you're my friend i'm not i'm not asking
you to take my back
i'm just letting you know what what's
here he was like all
gung-ho when he came back he was
heartbroken i guess he let the chick
from [ __ ]
baywatch a thousand bucks and she
promised to take him to a new year's eve
show at the [ __ ]
play boy branch or whatever she never
[ __ ] called them back
i'm telling you the movie was a mess but
what my point is
that what they do to your dream
those places i never [ __ ] got in bed
with
like that's what i meant when i was
saying that i'm sure that they've helped
a lot of people
second city has been the launch ground
for tons of people on saturday night
live
and i'm sure improv olympic helped a lot
of [ __ ] people i'm sure the
groundlings helped a lot of people
but i had a friend that was in the links
i had a dear friend that was a stand-up
and he was struggling as a stand-up
and he pulled me aside when then he goes
i'm joining the groundlings
for it to help me now i could have been
a douchebag and said what the [ __ ] are
you doing
i didn't say nothing because i wanted to
be open i wanted to say
well maybe the groundlings does help you
maybe it forces you to write from a
different perspective
maybe a [ __ ] you know whatever the
[ __ ] it is
i think he did it for like a year and a
half
he got more frustrated he packed up his
bags and went back to wherever the [ __ ]
he was from chicago and i never heard
from him again
so this is what i'm saying to you a lot
of people come to hollywood
and they got these big dreams and they
run into [ __ ] people basically like
me before i became a comic
that try to rob them their [ __ ]
integrity that's [ __ ] in my world
that's what i meant by it there's a
thousand bogus [ __ ] coaches in l.a
dog before i did that netflix thing the
half hour
i was going to an open mic place and one
of the things that bothered me the most
about going down there
was that they made you pay
five hours to get on stage
the whole time i paid the five and i
didn't say nothing i just shot up i
shut my mouth and i watched
why are you making young kids pay
five dollars to get on stage
i can look you guys straight in the
[ __ ] face and tell you
i've never paid to [ __ ] get on stage
during my early days
you either had to bring two people you
know set up the show
know the promoter you had to do some
type of work pass out flyers
but pay to go on stage
listen you know for a while there i was
thinking and i even bought the website
for
the last supper i was going to do a 12
when the covert really hit and i was
looking for options of what to do in l.a
just to stay busy
not even for financial gain just to stay
busy and to keep ahead of my game
i thought about there was a place across
the street from subconscious jiu jitsu
in north hollywood
and it was just a small place you know i
went in there a couple times the guy
wanted like four [ __ ] grand to rent a
closet
in l.a i tried to talk to him i said
listen why don't we do this
why don't we start at 2000 and grow
together and what my plan was to do was
to get
all those comics that you saw i put on
the church eric rocha
d'agostino dean del rey we had like 12
or 15 of us
people that you don't know people that
couldn't get on netflix because they
don't have an agent
but doesn't mean they're not [ __ ]
funny and it doesn't mean they're not
working and it doesn't mean they're not
[ __ ] humans
they're just not in the loop that's it
that's why i would put them on the
church when you saw a girl on there and
you were like who the [ __ ] is that
that was somebody who i saw out one
night and she was laying her soul down
on a [ __ ] stage
she was doing it every night regardless
of what guys were saying to her
there's no spots for women in l.a
whenever you saw me put a woman up in
my podcast it was because this woman was
[ __ ] going in their
head [ __ ] first and i supported that
i supported that so what i wanted to do
was
i wanted to have the last supper where
you came in
like a guy comes in you know one of us
and instead of a [ __ ] stranger or
some guy you're paying
telling you what the [ __ ] is wrong with
your set people that love you
tell you hey come here for a second
don't do that joke up front
save that for later because they already
see that you know there's different tips
you can tell people
that i know if i see theo at the store
and he does something you know if i see
you at anywhere at a pizza place
and you say something funny i'm gonna
come up to you and tell you it's [ __ ]
funny
that's the school i'm from you know but
ended there
i don't know what made it funny you just
had me laughing
and you know you guys know i don't laugh
at three quarters of this [ __ ]
you guys make me [ __ ] giggle it's
[ __ ] hysterical
so if i go into an open mic and you
crack a joke that's funny i'm gonna come
up to you and give you that type of
support
the other support like [ __ ] judging
your sex
i would never do that i would never
[ __ ] stomp on your dream who the [ __ ]
am i
to come to you what gay who gave me the
privilege to come to you
and say you [ __ ] you know i see these
young comics online
putting the senior specials down or
whatever who the [ __ ] are you
did you walk his [ __ ] journey did you
walk his journey
no so how can you sit there and say that
that [ __ ] comic sucks so this comic
sucks
this is what it's a delusion to me it's
[ __ ] delusional
when somebody sends me there's just so
much i could do as a human being
i will not come up to you and tell you
you [ __ ] sucked
in my [ __ ] 10 years on the podcast
there's only one comic i've said who's
[ __ ] sucked right out
and that's because it's true and they
were confused besides that
and they already knew they sucked they
already knew they sucked so 20 people
really told them that they sucked
and they were just a bad person but
beside that i i could never go up to a
young child and go i don't like that
[ __ ] joke
what those comedy schools what those
acting classes and all that after a
while you gotta nip them in the butt and
you gotta cut loose from them
that's exactly what i did with acting
and listen okay i didn't make it to the
greatest heights of the world
i'm no [ __ ] stanislavski but let me
tell you something look at a guy like
john bernthal this guy studied in
[ __ ] russia
he's a tremendous actor when you're on
the set with him he's creative
he knows little things but so does queen
latifah
so this iced tea iced tea has been on
[ __ ]
uh law and order svu for 22 years did he
go to [ __ ] rush and study
he probably had like an acting coach
that helped him through a couple scenes
and stuff like that
so there's different everybody has a
different [ __ ] journey of what you
want to do
my beef is people who don't know what
their journey is and they get involved
with these [ __ ] people these people
take them for all that [ __ ] money
that i don't believe in if anybody could
take you for any money in la
it could have been me i could have gone
to all those open mics
and talk i could have quit comedy i
could have quit doing a [ __ ] podcast
and trust me i could have got three of
those [ __ ] uh trust [ __ ] kids
and told them to pay me [ __ ] three
grand a week and guess what
they would have paid me because that's
just how it is now that you have no
idea what some people pay for the
[ __ ] dream
i can't charge you for a [ __ ] dream i
paid
33 dollars for my stand-up comedy class
in 1991 33
i think it was 31 there was a two dollar
[ __ ] charge or something like that
i paid 33
till this day i would do anything in the
world for jeff harms
he's a comic i think he lives in florida
i wish him all up in the world
he was as honest as could be for 33
dollars
you know how much a comedy cost charges
you in [ __ ] l.a
it would blow your [ __ ] mind
and then they promised you a set at the
legendary comedy school store at the end
or at the improv at the end or they
promised you a set of flappers at the
end
you know they all promise you something
at the end that's not gonna change your
world
yes i appreciate you taking a class i
took two of them
i took a class in colorado and then in
93
i took another one at new york comedy
club and i got one it was like an eight
week class
and again it was cheap because i was
broke and i was doing blow so i wasn't
going nope there was no
2 500 i was going to you know i gotta
get out of me
it was like maybe [ __ ] 80 bucks and
you could pay 10 bucks
a week when you went in and i remember
getting one thing out of that that
though today i use comedy is my world
that goes up against everybody else's
world that's all stand-up comedy is
so even for that 80 i got some but
there's people that way that'll charge
you
they make you go through their program
again
i'm not here to throw them under the bus
when you encounter them in either new
york
chicago l.a you'll know what the [ __ ]
i'm talking about
but nobody should get in front of your
[ __ ] dream no i didn't let nobody get
a friend of mine
i don't give a [ __ ] what you got to see
listen when you moved to l.a i had
agents telling me not to be dirty
to draw a family for them you know you
have to put your sitcom on the stage
[ __ ] you i'm doing dirty jokes and for
those people who run those acting
institutions
and those comedy places yeah you do help
a lot of people
but at the other hand you heard a lot of
people also
because instead of taking their money
like if i was taking your money if you
came to me
and you said i i'm the type of guy that
also tell you
that you have to change things around or
you're not going to [ __ ] stand the
chance
you know with comedy comedy to become a
good comedian
it's not hard it is hard
but it's not hard you gotta keep to the
[ __ ] grind every day
and you gotta [ __ ] love it and you
gotta
have tough skin that's it that's the
toughest part of this
if peop is people telling you you suck
for six years how does that feel
i'm thinking waking up every day and
nobody even has to tell you you suck
life tells you you suck when you go to a
comedy room and they don't put you up
when you go to a comedy room and nobody
talks to you after your [ __ ] set
what about when life just tells you you
[ __ ] suck so now
that's fine i can live with that life
telling me i suck
i can accept that but me paying a
[ __ ] comedy guy
or some [ __ ] improv school at the top
it's a waste of my [ __ ] time
i don't know if you've got anything from
this conversation today if you haven't i
did
because i wanted to [ __ ] just rectify
what the [ __ ] my statements were last
week
i don't like when people get in front of
people's dreams bro that's just
not it's not gonna work for me it's
monday morning
you gotta [ __ ] dream you go for it if
someone like you ever tell your parents
like even like an uncle that you're
thinking of becoming something they
giggle at you
i [ __ ] got those people out of my
life in the [ __ ] very early beginning
anybody who questioned me doing comedy i
got rid of
and that was why like i mentioned
eventually she's still there
it's still a great acting school i know
a lot of people who go there i know a
lot of people who work there
but even there i don't want you to get
stuck in that
i don't want you to get stuck in [ __ ]
learning i want you to get stuck and
doing
if you're gonna do anything you got to
do it i'm seeing all these things on
facebook now
to learn how to do a podcast get a
[ __ ] mic
get a [ __ ] phone get two cans and
just talk
nobody could teach you how to do a
podcast you guys were in shock last week
oh my god joey we know we never heard
you
talk about how it's turned before in
your life what the [ __ ] do you think
i've been doing all my life
i didn't have the three hours to sit
there every morning and listen to how
it's turned
but i did have the internet and once
those clips started popping up on the
internet especially with audi lang
if you don't think i watched those
things you're out of your mind
that's what you invest your time in
watching the best
that was [ __ ] radio history in my
world
when audie lang was on [ __ ] stern
that was radio history yes
i did watch those i paid attention and i
also paid attention that was the
beginning of podcasting
because everybody else was just doing
radio hey this is a song from johnny
hey this howard stern would make you
[ __ ] say uncomfortable [ __ ]
that's what a podcast is supposed to be
a podcast isn't [ __ ] radio
it's not the fake voice hey and you keep
replugging it that's why
i'll see you and uncle joey's joint with
it that's not [ __ ] radio that that's
radio
that's not a [ __ ] podcast a ton of
people have contacted me hey i was in
radio for 20 years
really go [ __ ] yourself that's great but
you can't help me
because i'm doing a podcast you dumb
[ __ ] howard stern was the first one that
did the crossover into the podcast
because he got deep with you
he got personal with you already telling
you he'd been with hookers already
telling you he went to cop in harlem the
night before
that's his personals can [ __ ] get
[ __ ] dave clark
who's the guy that hosted new year's eve
with the [ __ ] big head at the end
dick clark he never [ __ ] told you
that he had a drug problem or
none of these people told you nothing
from the heart they just told you you
wanted to hear
it wasn't until [ __ ] howard stern a
couple dudes like that
that started opening up that's where the
podcast comes from the podcast ain't
radio
so when you radio people call me and say
hey i've been doing radio for 20 years i
have an idea for you really you got no
idea for you
well you know why radio is dead how many
stations are left 11
how many so don't hit me with radio
podcasting is completely different if
you see those [ __ ] ads on facebook
just [ __ ] tell them go [ __ ] yourself
how can you teach me
how to do a podcast you're not doing a
podcast
how can you teach me how to do a podcast
where's your [ __ ] podcast
so how can you teach me do not sign up
for those things if you want to do a
podcast
get a mic you get it from amazon
a [ __ ] iphone i don't care how you do
it a [ __ ] gopro
there's a thousand things you could do
and start talking start opening yourself
up start telling people [ __ ] that
nobody else has said people that only
you could [ __ ] write that only you
could say
only i [ __ ] mugged the hooker a
little wig on fire
only i got into a fight with a [ __ ]
nun that's what people want to hear
about you
not what you want them to [ __ ] say so
all these [ __ ] courses that they sell
you
and i see those prices on those podcast
[ __ ] things they want like 1100 hours
oh come to our conference
to do what to talk to 20 other people
ain't doing nothing
20 other people when i do my podcast
when
when when are you gonna [ __ ] do your
podcast when are you gonna make the jump
to the next [ __ ] step
so before you get into a podcast school
a comedy school
an improv school or whatever [ __ ]
acting school think about it
you're gonna go in there take what's
necessary and move the [ __ ] on
it's not gonna be an eight year [ __ ]
acting career it's not gonna be eight
years
of listening to joey once a week oh and
stand up
you can't you have to open up with your
second best joke and closing it
i can't milk you for that long it's
maybe [ __ ] four weeks listen when you
go on stage
don't focus on this don't look at their
faces to you know because
a lot of people have fear i can help you
overcome fear and little things like
that
but i can't tell you what direction to
take it because we all have a different
journey
you have to [ __ ] live that journey i
can't tell you what your journey's going
to be
if i can tell you what that journey is
going to be do you think i'd be sitting
here with a [ __ ] iphone in my face
i'd be somewhere at a [ __ ] shop
window charging you fifty dollars to
tell you your [ __ ] future
i know your future but i will tell you
your journey's gonna be [ __ ] hard if
you get into comedy
acting stand-up podcasting that's why i
love you guys i always have advice on
[ __ ] podcasting
where's your [ __ ] podcast oh look he
would be a good guest on your show
where's your [ __ ] show
put them on your [ __ ] show if you
love them so much i don't know that
[ __ ] dude i've never heard before
in my life but you like them so [ __ ]
you put them on your show so whatever's
char
whether [ __ ] is trying to sell you on
anything i don't mind
you going in there to get the basics
you know jiu jitsu listen i i'm not
arguing i'm not talking about jiu jitsu
schools
you got to keep going just to school for
10 years before you get your black belt
you know karate you have to get your
black belt but comedy whatever all you
need is the basics
and a microphone you know an improv
troop
you can write the stuff yourself and let
me tell you something
you're talking to somebody who went the
improv olympic
i later on after the longest shot i told
you guys i had weird feelings about
stand up
so i thought i wanted to write sketches
so one day i went to improv olympic
what let me tell you this story
correctly what happened was
improv olympic had an open mic friday
night late
and i stopped going to the store after
the whole rogan thing in 2007 2008
so i was looking for different places to
perform
i lived on schrader in hollywood
and two blocks over was
the best hot the best weed store ever
kushmart and up the corner was improv
olympic
so from me going to that weed store i
looked at their schedule and i saw they
had an open mic
and i went down there friday night and
there was agents
and managers from everywhere
they wouldn't [ __ ] talk to me but i
couldn't believe
that all these agents and managers were
at the improv olympic on a friday night
so i started going to all the open mics
on friday nights there
and i started doing great there and i
started meeting people and one day i
took a schedule home and had like intro
to sketch
writing you know and i signed up i did
the eight-week class the ten-week class
it wasn't that expensive again i didn't
have that [ __ ] money for that
type of [ __ ] and then i got into intro
to writing sketches too
and then one day i went for a [ __ ]
job to write sketches
like i wrote like three sketches for
some [ __ ] company or some [ __ ]
i went down there and the guy's like
this ain't bad did you ever write
sketches before i go no i just
took a class the guy goes where i go
then pro olympic he goes what's the
guy's name i told him the guy's name
and the guy just reamed me out he goes
that guy's a [ __ ] bum
he gets fired from every job why the
[ __ ] is he teaching down there
and then i went home and actually looked
up the guy and the guy was a bum he was
an honkey and [ __ ] like that
so i said [ __ ] it i'm not going over
there no more why would i take and then
i found out the guy was just a [ __ ]
jerk off and
but i he taught me something i took one
thing from him
so it was worth it for the [ __ ]
whatever was a buck quarter and a
quarter
i learned a few things from him but i
got the [ __ ] out so i don't want you to
think that no there's people you can
learn things from
i just don't want you to get caught up
in that world and let them tell you
how to work your career it's your
[ __ ] career figure it the [ __ ] out
when i was going to acting class there
were people in that class i don't even
think they watched a [ __ ] movie
i don't think they watched the movie
they just wanted
what came with the movie later with the
success
but before i did they were that bad they
were that bad
and then i would go up there and they
would go how the [ __ ] do you
i'm a stand-up i came from a different
[ __ ] world you came right from
college
you've never been on stage before and
now you you're pissed off
and i mean these kids would say things
i'd feel so bad for them
they would go you're not going to
believe it next week in acting class i'm
doing the scene from carlito's way that
was a big thing for them
meanwhile i'm doing [ __ ] movies i'm
auditioning i'm in there [ __ ] every
day
i felt horrible so
last week's [ __ ] podcast when i said
that [ __ ]
that's where it stems from i got no
hatred i got no beef
all i'm pissed off is that you gotta do
instead of [ __ ] learn sometimes
when it comes to stand-up all that [ __ ]
is the same
and that's it and that's that i don't
know what else to tell you [ __ ]
it's monday this [ __ ] spray is
starting to [ __ ] shine and i got [ __ ]
to do
and i know you [ __ ] got [ __ ] to
do but i'm happy you subscribed
i'm happy you're watching uncle joey's
joint and i'm happy you're enjoying it
if you're not enjoying it turn it off
and watch something else
we all can't love the same [ __ ] thing
if not it wouldn't be [ __ ] the world
right or wrong
and with that that's it and that's that
this wednesday i'm going to try it again
at uncle vinnie's because i'm that type
of [ __ ]
and the wednesday after that i'm going
to try again because i'm that type of
[ __ ] and if i
bomb my bomb and that's it that's what i
am as a [ __ ] comic
so i absorbed it i got it and i feel you
i love you guys thank you for tuning in
to uncle joey's joint
and if you learned something today learn
i'd rather you
do than sit in a [ __ ] classroom and
take some [ __ ]
lessons from some [ __ ] stiff that's
never even lived the [ __ ] journey
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
have your own journey log everything
down and you're gonna be fine
i love you [ __ ] thank you very
much for watching
now for a word from our sponsors
all right i had a great time to you with
you [ __ ] today
and now it's that time when i drop some
knowledge on you listen
uncle joy's joint is brought to you by
blue chew
guys remember the days when your [ __ ]
dick would be hard just by you blowing
on it
things change you get older things start
coming into your life you start getting
a little stress
and then you got weak wood uncle joey's
got the fix for you all right
blue chew you're like joy what the [ __ ]
is blue chew blue chew is the first
chewable dick bill
all right that's right it's a dick pill
same fda approved acting
ingredients as viagra and cyalis
this isn't the horny goat weed you get
from [ __ ] that dude at the corner
store that looks like
he just got out of prison this is
[ __ ] science
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor's
office and make eye contact with a
creepy doctor
who thinks you're [ __ ] up because you
don't get a heart on and then you know
you don't have to even go out the
[ __ ] pharmacy it ships right to your
door to the discrete package
nobody knows nothing blue chew is
cheaper than the [ __ ] pharmacy
and you can take them anytime day and
night even on a full stomach
right now they got a special offer for
the shirt
for the joint family visit bluechew.com
that's blue
b-l-u-e chew calm and get your first
shipment free when you're pressing code
joey
and just pay five dollars shipping
that's it again that's blue like the
color of your dick
i'm telling you right now when you get
these pills and you give mama a stab and
it's all over the shot
but you gotta hit the bluetooth dog
bluetooth.com
use promo code joey again that's
bluetooth.com
use promo code joey the church is also
brought to you by
honey listen what the [ __ ] we're living
online right
you're buying [ __ ] every [ __ ] day
every day you got to order this you got
to order that
it's a [ __ ] nightmare whether it's
the generator the macbook
now that's where today's sponsor comes
in honey they come in handy and i'm
going to tell you why it's a free
browser extension
which is like a little ferry that lives
inside your computer who looks all over
the [ __ ] internet for a promo code
to save you money listen right now it's
a time to save money
it's easy just download honey at
joinhoney.com
again join honey joinhoney.com
joey then when you got something in your
cart honey will pop up and show you all
the promo codes
you can use to save some dough the best
part is
honey will automatically find you the
best discounts available
i've saved a ton of money my wife on
school supplies for my daughter
she goes back to school today full time
there's no reason reason to pay retail
for [ __ ] pencils
money has honey has already saved over
two billion dollars for their users
right now you got to take back those
every [ __ ] dollar you can and honey
works
with everything from online gaming sites
to clothes
even fees on food delivery and it's easy
if you got a computer
honey should be on it's that [ __ ]
simple it's free and it works with
whatever browser you use
you can get honey for free today at
jointhoney.com
joey again that's joint hunting.com
joey joinhoney.com
joey you filthy [ __ ] the church
is also brought to you by and this is
the perfect week to get your [ __ ]
groove going
from the heart of new jersey uncle
joey's joining brought to you by
draftkings
again tonight you got the bills against
the chiefs
who the [ __ ] are you gonna bet the over
the under whatever the [ __ ] you're gonna
do
this weekend you got khabib against
justin gagey i don't know when the world
series is starting
but you got [ __ ] action [ __ ]
and draftking
is america's top rated sportsbook app if
you haven't tried it yet you're [ __ ]
slipping it's time to jump on
because they're going all [ __ ] in
with new users
they're gonna give you a chance to give
you a thousand dollars
when you sign up with a bonus when you
use code joey
so go to [ __ ] draftkings.com right
now and just sign up
use code joey and they'll give you a
grant you put in a grand
they give you a grant who else has given
you anything these [ __ ] days
get to the app store and download the
draftkings now
and here's a new offer for mma fans turn
a dollar
into a hundred how okay i'll tell you
bet on this weekend's ufc 254
fight they're practically paying you to
watch one of these best fights of the
[ __ ] year
khabib versus gagey the best part is
draftkings is based right here in the
u.s it's safe
secure and reliable you deposit
withdrawal money at your own convenience
and it's your [ __ ] account it's not
three dudes in abu dhabi
he's telling you his name is [ __ ]
saheed but his name is carl
this is draftking so do me a favor
download the top-rated draftking sports
app now
and use code joey to get a thousand
[ __ ] dollars
did you hear what i'm saying you get a
thousand dollars when you get the
draftking sports book app
and use promo code joey only at
draftkings sportsbook and here's the
part
the lawyers make you say you must be 21
or older
new jersey indiana or pennsylvania only
deposit
bonus requires a 20 time five times play
through
restrictions do apply you gotta see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details if you got a
gaming problem
there's help call one eight hundred
gambler
here in indiana called 1-809 with it but
if you ain't got no [ __ ] problems
download the draftking sports book app
today
and use code joey okay i want to thank
draftkings
i want to thank honey i want to thank
bluetooth but most importantly i want to
thank you [ __ ] savages
for always having my back you understand
me stay black have a great week and the
party starts today
there you go lights out [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you